hey everyone it's my photos and I'm
happy to announce on Thursday October
19th I am taking part in investor
inspirations online pro trader workshop
and it runs from 11:00 a.m. Eastern Time
until it was for 4:45 4:30 Eastern time
is we have 7 speakers lined up yep Dale
Bret Howard Steve Koenig Vince Forrest
and fry Feld myself Randy Howell and
Steve primo speaking so I love that name
Steve primo what's your name Steve Remo
it sounds like something I had a lot of
The Simpsons so you can watch us live as
we take you step-by-step through the
training strategies and techniques that
have made us successful in our own ways
now seats for this virtual event are
free but they're limited you know so
reserve your spot now by going to the
sign up link below in the description or
you can go to my website order closed
comm slash sign up that HTML and when I
say you know it's limited
you know goatee runs through GoToWebinar
so you could watch it from your home or
your office or your handphone even but
you know GoToWebinar has a limit of the
amount of people that could attend live
at any at any moment so at least sign up
for it because even if you can't attend
I understand you know people work during
the day
or you know they're busy with their kids
in school I understand that completely
so at least if you sign up you'll be on
the list
to get the replay when it becomes
available so what you're going to learn
in this online trading conference is how
to beat the market makers by trading
weekly options change your forex trading
forever trading with price bars
profiting from delta-neutral positions
myself I'll be talking about order flow
what's it gonna take to get you to the
next level in your trading and how to
fine-tune your entries with our new
technique called steps so again you know
if you can't attend at least register
for the event because then at least you
can get the webinar replays for the day
and you can watch you know watch it you
know over the weekend or you know in the
evening that same day and you know
surely you got to come away with
something you got seven speakers each
person is going to be talking about
their their own thing so be sure to sign
up and be sure to attend you know it's
you know just really quick right this is
this is what the topics
we'll be covered here let me make that a
little smaller you know you know we got
options you got price bars obviously
order flows Steve Primo's be talking
about this new technique on steps and
you know this one I find really
interesting this one is by Randy Howell
he speaks after me okay what's gonna
take to get you to the next level in
your trading and you know a lot of
people you know we all talk about you
know the methods of our trading but a
big part of training is your your mind
right here your make up your mind so
when these talks about what's gonna take
you to the next level in your trainees
we talking about your emotions you know
that the housing holding you back how it
affects your performance keep your head
together in the clutch and you know
develop a probability based mind for
effective training I think that's gonna
be a very interesting presentation again
that one comes right after myself that's
by this fella here Randy Howell traders
state of mind right here he's at 3:30
p.m. Eastern time I speak just ahead of
them at 2:45 so you know I think it's
gonna be a great great knowing which
won't call it a great conference so be
sure to sign up so at least you could at
the very least if you can't attend live
you could get access to the recordings
you know that's that's the that that's
where the real gold gold nuggets is
going to come out of again you know
sometimes you know you watch these
things you're busy you got stuff going
on in the background you can't
concentrate but you know if you watch it
a second time you pick up things that
you missed so a brief disclaimer you
know these presentations and this video
is educational and informational
purposes only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision future train
contains your stance or risk and it's
not for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk apples might not
be lost without jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle only
risk capital should be used for trading
and only those was official risk capital
should consider trading passports it's
not necessarily indicative of future
results so again you know to sign up
it's on Thursday October 19th
today is Monday the 15th I'm sorry
Monday the 16th what am I talking about
and go to WWE or fellows comm signup
that's through my website I put a direct
link down below which will take you
directly to investor inspiration it's
better if you sign up through through my
link that I put in the description below
or through order closed so thanks
everyone and I hope to see you guys
there
bye bye